all right
we are now live for sort of an impromptu
uh live streaming session
um I found out today looking at Facebook
she has all these memories that five
years ago today I effectively started
the Sadler's lectures podcast and I
thought I would do a little celebration
five years in now at this point and
we've done more than just a little bit
more than 900 episodes so I thought it
was kind of a cool Milestone and I
figured I would do a live chat so people
who wanted to get in on Liberation or
find out more about it could and so I
figured you know the only the only real
thing that got sort of schedule is I'll
tell you a little bit about the podcast
and how I got started and you know maybe
what we've got on the docket yet to come
down the line about it and uh so anyway
for years and years and years so we're
going further than five years back you
know I had a lot of people saying I like
your YouTube lectures do you think you
could turn them into podcast episodes
because I like listening to them but
it's eating up my cellular data or I can
download your your videos of course and
I'd love to be able to download podcast
episodes
so I thought about it for a while and I
was like well
yeah I guess I could do that I mean it's
taking on some additional work and so I
put it into patreon is like one of the
things one of the goals after I reached
a certain point
where I would I would start doing
podcast episodes and I started thinking
about what kind of videos would I do so
you know the longer class videos
not really great for making into podcast
episodes not least because they're a lot
of work you know taking
um
a video and turning it into a podcast
episode I'll tell you what what that
involves in a bit but doing it like an
hour-long class yeah I don't know that's
that's an awful lot here I want to put
myself in for that much extra effort
and uh so then I started thinking about
what about the core concept videos and
at that time I probably had like
you know two or three hundred maybe more
core concept videos
those are you know something I've
started doing for my own students and a
lot of other people benefit from them
they're nice because they're like you
know anywhere from 10 to 20 minutes long
and that could make a good podcast
episode so I started doing that and
actually at the very beginning of doing
that
um I started creating my own and I think
the very first episodes I had were
Play-Doh maybe from the Mino or one of
the other dialogues right and I got
audacity and audacity is this free
software that you can use I still use it
today for the podcast I use it for
producing the wisdom for Life uh Radio
Show episodes and it's you know it's
cool it's it's it's you know maybe
there's some other software out there
that's better than that but I'm pretty
happy with the way audacity works and
the kind of um episodes you know the
kind of sound files that it produces
it's got a big learning curve
I will say that and so some of the
earliest episodes are perhaps not at
their best because I wasn't quite sure
how to use effects like compression at
that time but in any case I would take
them and so I brought the sound I
brought the I downloaded the videos
brought them in to audacity which turned
them into sound files clipped off the
intro and the the final uh silent outro
stuff and then I started doing what you
do with with these podcast episodes
which is boosting the sound quality and
getting rid of any sort of unnecessary
words like you know
um uh
repeated words long pauses breaths all
that that sort of stuff you hear me just
do that that right I'd get rid of one of
the that's in that case
so then I started uploading them and I
started putting them out there and
people liked them so I started uh
building that part of the SoundCloud
Channel and then people were like well I
like that it's on Soundcloud but I get
my stuff through Apple podcast or
Spotify or stuff like that so then I had
to figure out okay how do you get the
RSS feed from the one in SoundCloud to
the other and that's what I did and I
think now
Sadler's lectures is available on
probably 20 major sites and a whole
bunch of other ones that I don't know
about but keep finding out about every
once in a while when somebody will point
it out to me hey you're on this or that
and then I just kept like uh turning him
out and then I I realized that as I'm
shooting the new
um lecture videos especially once I got
myself this uh voice recorder and
started using it with the lapel mic that
you you've probably seen over the last I
don't know
three four years
well I could take the sound files and
not screw around with the videos anymore
and just put the sound files themselves
right into audacity and then Tinker
around with them there and so that's
what I've been doing
and
I've kept up with it and I use these uh
podcast episodes as resources for my own
students in my own classes you know even
in my face-to-face classes I'll often
Supply them with my videos and also
podcast episodes and it's a nice
resource for the students when they're
out of class if they're you know like
let's say they're looking at seneca's on
anger as they have in classes the last
two semesters
um if they want to download episodes
with me giving lectures on it and go
through them they can listen to it while
they're at the gym or doing work or you
know whatever and it's really kind of
Handy for them and so you know I've just
kept churning away at it and I've now
got over
uh 900 episodes
now there is something to say about that
I discovered this once I got past the
500 episode Mark if you want to hear the
full 900 episodes they're only available
on Soundcloud because one of the thing
that all of these big podcast
um RSS
assimilators do is they only give you
the last 500. so if you go to Apple
podcasts you're only getting about half
of the full stuff that I I have if you
go to Spotify if you go to as klug is
pointing out uh Google podcast you're
not getting the entire set of 900 you're
only getting the latest 500 but there is
uh something kind of good and you can
see it in the video description I've put
the podcast episodes into
uh playlists and I've created a medium
page or article where I've linked to
every one of those playlists and I've
organized them according to like ancient
medieval early modern 19th century and
then you know different types of 20th
century philosophy and literature and
psychology
so it's pretty easy to find the episodes
if you're looking for them and I mean
most of them are on philosophy some are
literature I'm going to be doing some
later this summer
um of some of the Philip K dick stuff
that I've done in Ursula K Le Guin as
well
um some of the shorter speculative
fiction studies videos and
um yeah it's it's become something that
I'm you know pretty good at doing
um I don't actually have like what we
could call a real podcast where I'm like
you know coming on just to talk about
stuff and not taking lectures and
turning them into podcasts but that's
going to come down the line
um once I have a little bit more time
I'll probably be taking some of those
um
those uh conversations that matter
videos that I do the interviews and
turning them into podcast episodes and
I'll probably be doing some podcast
episodes with my own like Reflections
and musings on things maybe people you
know would enjoy that that sort of thing
I don't know but uh yeah so the Sadler's
lectures podcast you know it's not going
away anytime soon and it's turned into a
useful resource and maybe source of
entertainment for quite a few people so
that's kind of cool so I thought I would
um tell you the story and we'd celebrate
a bit we'll see how long this goes on I
got myself a nice non-alcoholic beer uh
from groovy and mocha Nitro Stout and uh
which takes an awful lot like Guinness
they they managed to get it pretty good
so I I'll uh take your con some question
marks congratulations glad to see you
here Mark Mark and I go back back quite
a ways uh clueless says congratulations
I listened to those on Google podcast
you're one of the few my stats show that
a lot of people listen to sound
SoundCloud A Lot through Apple podcasts
a lot through Spotify and then it just
kind of goes downward from from there
not too many people because Google sends
me the stats not too many people
listening to it on Google podcasts but
I'm glad you're one of them uh kluga
says hope you keep doing it I find it
very useful that's that's great I'm I'm
glad that you're finding the podcast
episodes useful
I mean they are covering exactly the
same ground as the core concept videos
that they're taken from but you know
they're a little bit more listenable I
think you know when you've got like the
chalkboard and standing up in front of
it it's a little bit more forgiving for
all the verbal ticks the ums the eyes
the you knows that I say so frequently
but you know like I just said there I
think in podcasts when you're just
listening to it you don't want that
stuff in there quite so much so
uh Ken Blackwell is here uh somebody who
also we go quite a ways back as as metal
heads congrats on the 900th episode
quite a milestone for a single podcast
series
yeah I can't say that I like most things
I I start them up and I don't really
think about where they're going or how
much work they're going to be or what
what the you know eventual Legacy of
them is going to be if you had told me
years ago yeah you'll have 900 episodes
um I probably would have said nah that's
that's never going to happen but sure
enough we got to 900 episodes and I
think that's you know that's pretty cool
hit a thousand I'm sure before the end
of the year right because we still have
another
um you know
we're in mid-may we got another seven
months to go so we'll definitely be at a
thousand before too long if I get
another you know 25 of them done each
month which is my current rate
so that that's pretty cool and I'm glad
all of you could be here you know with
me to chat about this and commemorate it
a bit
um anybody else have any comments or
questions they'd like me to uh address
about the podcast about philosophy about
plans for it as a matter of fact I I was
supposed to say something about the
plans for it so the plans are just keep
on going
you know right now I'm editing today
more episodes on seneca's on anger book
two and then we'll do book three and
I've got some Philip K dick stuff to do
and then I've got some Marcus Aurelius
uh meditations things that I shot in the
last couple months about his uh views on
anger and some stoic practices and each
one of those will get turned into a
podcast episode uh and then you know
we'll just see where we go from there
there's plenty of stuff and I will
mention too
that at this point I have managed to
produce podcast episodes covering the
entirety of the Nico McCann ethics
uh all of Cicero's book one of on duties
um what else have we got like some
platonic dialogues totally covered not
the Republic of course but
um you know the Fado and the amino and
the Symposium all of that's been covered
the apology
uh what else have I done
oh and Anselm's monologian uh his
untruth his uh dialogue
um on freedom of choice kant's
prologometer or not prolonged accounts
groundwork
um Descartes meditations
there's quite a few where we've like
done enough to cover the entire work
which is
pretty cool because it makes it a a
really helpful resource if somebody
wants to study those things on their own
you could like you know listen to them
over the course of a week and work your
way through a text so reflective Journey
says congratulations thanks
people join me for this
see if anybody else has any questions or
comments that they want me to uh read
and respond to
I'll mention too a bit of a digression
so you know I'm drinking non-alcoholic
beer these days because
um can't drink anymore with the
medication that I'm on and it used to be
in the old days that non-alcoholic beer
just sucked but now there's pretty good
stuff you know
so there's a lot of cool Brewers out
there groovy is is one of them
um the two Roots you know there's
there's a bunch of other ones as well
athletic Brewing Company and uh you know
I've come to realize that what I really
was after was not so much that getting
buzzed which can be nice but you can
dispense with and it's more the uh The
Taste the flavors the profiles the mouth
feel of the the beers you know I've been
drinking beer since I was in high school
you know we're we're doing it illegally
um and then I got in the Army and got to
drink really good beer when I was
stationed in Germany and picked up a
taste for it and then came back here
where we had one of the earliest micro
breweries the sprecker brewery here in
in Milwaukee
so I'm kind of I'm kind of into that all
right so so Ken has a possible Niche
question I found I find uh mussonius
Rufus much more difficult to read than
Seneca Epictetus or Marcus
did he write with a different style or
is this more of an issue with
translations that's a great question I
mean what we have of Rufus
are basically just lectures and then
these fragments and I don't know if
there's
I don't know if there's multiple
translations out there or not the
original is in the Greek
and
I don't you know read him just in the
Greek I usually read in English and then
whenever something seems a little bit
weird or hinky then I'll go back to the
original language like I typically do
with other authors and I I don't find
his Greek particularly tricky
um
so I I don't know I mean Epictetus can
Epictetus can sometimes be tricky to
read and so can Seneca
um Seneca not least because he loves his
rhetorical
framing of things as a matter of fact
the in Antiquity sometimes they are in
the Middle Ages they would like say
Cicero is one model of rhetoric Seneca
another model of rhetoric
I think part of the challenge with
mussonius is we just don't have that
much whereas like with Seneca we got
tons and tons of his writings even with
Marcus Aurelius we've got considerably
more than mussonius
um I will say this when we're reading
you didn't ask directly about about
Marcus Aurelius but I'm going to say
this when we read Marcus Aurelius we got
to be really careful about the
translations because they often can be
misleading even among people who are
like viewed as you know good recent
translators because they'll translate
stuff in ways that gives rise to
misunderstandings like you know saying
for example
everything is opinion well that's not
what Marcus actually says he'll say at a
certain point everything is
assumption right which is not the same
thing as doxa or dogmata opinion and
translators will just put that in there
and then people will like throw the
quote around and it gets everybody
confused so
[Music]
um
all right Mark says
uh do you have any comments on the
nature of theories found in the
Christian prayer tradition in Plato and
Aristotle how are they the same or
different no I don't really have any
comments on that because I wasn't
prepared to like do any deep thinking
about you know those sorts of things I
will say this that theoria is is not
something that has just one meaning in
Aristotle it changes from work to work
and likewise and Plato and the Christian
prayer tradition there isn't any
Christian prayer tradition there's a
whole bunch of Christian prayer
Traditions some of which are going to be
written by people indebted to Plato or
Aristotle so it's it's not like there's
you know box one over here box two over
here in box three over here
all right uh uh ronelius are you
planning to create a guide to
translations or learning ancient
languages no not at all I'm not a I'm
not a classicist I'm a person who reads
Classical Languages but that's work
that's much better left to people who
specialize in that sort of work
um and there's plenty of you know guides
to learning ancient languages already
available out there you just have to
Google it and you'll you'll find them
I didn't use that sort of stuff when I
was learning them I I looked through the
grammars and worked my way all the way
through them and you know but I learned
languages in different ways
and it wouldn't why would I make a guide
to translations
um if you mean like guides for people to
do translations that seems like such a
niche that
um it wouldn't be particularly helpful
for me to do it I mean I do translate
stuff from various languages but
I'm not there to guide other people in
doing that
um
all right have you read the new
Wittgenstein tract hottest translation
by Oxford World Classics I haven't but I
mean I don't really care because if I
want to read
um the tractatus I just read it in
German you know that's that's what I cut
my teeth on when I was first
encountering Wittgenstein
oh about
you know 25 30 years ago so
there being a new tractatus translation
for me that doesn't really that's not a
big deal there's a lot of other works
where maybe it'd be more interesting to
see a new translation
um
reflective journey I am planning to go
through Robert Brandon's a spirit of
trust is that a good place to start with
Hegel uh no you should start with
reading Hegel I mean or if you're gonna
like if you want a secondary source I
don't know start with uh something
that's less taking a stand on hegel's
work and something that's just like more
standard history of philosophy like
Cobblestone and that would be the place
to go but if you're going to start with
Hegel
um you know start I always say not with
the phenomenology with which the spirit
of trust is about by the way but with
his lectures on the philosophy of
history and lectures on the history of
philosophy and there's a I recently did
a
self-directed study video on hegel's
works so just you know Google Sadler
self-directed study Hegel and that'll
give you all sorts of ideas and
resources and things like that
um
all right uh ronia said I mean maybe a
guide to find the best translations of
certain works I have a video uh which is
one of the Dr Sadler responds people
always ask me what's the best
translation of this and I say there is
no such thing as the best translation
that's that's not the way translation
works there might be some translations
that are crappy but you know there's
rarely a hands down best translation
it's all depending on what you're
looking for do you want it to be real
close to the text do you want it to be
you know sort of like getting at the
heart of the things do you want it to be
in colloquial language there there's no
Universal best translation for most
works
uh Mark says congratulations on the
Milestone Greg here's to further success
with with some beers yeah thanks Mark uh
we have a little toast if any of you
have anything that you're imbibing these
are some some uh glasses pint glasses
that we got from the Milwaukee Repertory
uh theater just recently and I've got as
I was mentioning my non-alcoholic micro
mocha Stout
mocha Nitro Stout rather so all right
um
so
polymathon could you share your thoughts
and personal experience on the
connection between being a musician and
honing one's philosophical soul
um I mean I don't have a lot of thoughts
on that because being a musician is
something I do sort of on the side it's
not something that I do to hone my
philosophical Soul
um it's something I more or less do for
enjoyment and because I like
um playing and singing the music at
least the bits of it I can do that I I
love so I don't I have I've done that
somebody would be good ask about that
would be my friend Scott taruli
who is a musician like a professional
musician and a guitar professor and has
been studying philosophy with me for
years and years and years and he's also
become a good friend and colleague
um so you know he might be somebody good
to to reach out to
clue what determines the order of the
episodes or how you decide what to cover
so another good podcast question they
appear to be completely random jumping
from Descartes to Epictetus for example
so they appear to be random but they're
not random it's whatever I decide I need
to work on at the time you know like I
said earlier I produced the the podcast
episodes as resources for my students so
if I've got stuff on hand that I've shot
videos on and I'm like yeah I need this
for my students that's what goes into
the hopper
um
you know all the podcast episodes are
produced up to this point from core
concept videos so obviously that narrows
considerably I've got close to 3 000
videos total and probably a thousand of
them are core concept videos
and you know 900 of them have been
turned into podcast episodes
so you know they're all things that I
have previously produced things on and
um
I just keep you know producing new core
concept videos and then I need to keep
producing new Sadler's lectures podcasts
trying to catch up to where I've been
uh Mark Trumbull says I read three
quarters of Hegel on world history and
got much out of it yeah it's it's a good
book I mean it's not as if like we take
Hegel and we're like yeah hagel's
completely right about everything but
um you know it's uh
it's um
yeah it's good to to check out
all right uh Patrick says
congratulations on your podcast
Milestone might you consider discussing
the work of Eric pizarroa or modern
Catholic understandings of the analogia
enters more broadly
hey if you want to commission me to
shoot videos on that and then produce
podcast episodes that's fine but I I
don't have any plans to shoot on uh
priswara at any point in time right now
I got plenty of other stuff I gotta
produce things on if we want to talk
about contemporary or you know 20th
century Catholic thinkers uh you know I
did my dissertation on Maurice Blondell
I should probably start doing some core
concept videos on that guy first and
there's plenty of Gabriel Marcel I need
to do stuff on on tonight
um
there's so many other thinkers that I
would probably get to before him but if
you want to Pony up the money and and
hire me to produce the videos that you
want to see I'm always game for that
I've done that before with Nietzsche and
Heidegger and a few other things that
people really really wanted
um sumits love and greetings from India
your lectures are full of wisdom and
very helpful to me thank you
um well I'm glad to glad to hear that by
the way interestingly a bit of a side
note trivia I've done work in the past
prepping students for the Indian Civil
Service examination which you know you
may know uh Sumit and but I doubt many
of the other people do
it has quite a bit of philosophy stuff
in it you know for the Indian civil
service exam there are the required
um test things that you have to do
and one of them includes an Ethics
component right and that that was in
there in part because there was so much
corruption going on that they thought it
was important but there's also like you
can you know you can study all these
different subject areas and so
I you know there's uh Western and Indian
philosophy and so I've I've prepped test
candidates in both of those in the past
it's been a while so I haven't looked at
the most recent sets of questions
um but if I ever do have the time I may
produce some resources on that because I
always thought it was pretty cool that
you know there's at least one place
as far as I know that thinks that you
should know some philosophy and be able
to explain it to other people before
they'll let you in governance positions
or at least in civil service positions
and so I I kind of like that idea
all right
um
mbbm is it necessary if one desires to
learn philosophy to enroll academically
no it's not necessary you can study
philosophy on your own and
you could also enroll in a traditional
academic institution and have crappy
teachers that you know aren't very good
at teaching philosophy or aren't very
interested in what they're teaching I
will say this
um
I don't think that we should
make it you know like there's two boxes
non-academic and academic because a lot
of the people that you're going to be
relying upon like let's say you're
watching my videos so I'm an academic
right and some of the videos are
actually from classes or they've been
used to you know teach online classes
um
you're getting something that maybe you
yourself participate in without
enrolling in an academic institution but
it's partly the fruit of academic study
of philosophy and academic settings for
philosophy right
so if it wasn't for the fact that I've
derived an income continually from
teaching
really since the before the 2000s I I
taught my first class in 1999.
um I probably
wouldn't have had the
the space and the capacity to produce
all these videos right because it's not
like YouTube is making me Rich or
something like that
um so you know it's not as it's not so
simple as there's academic philosophy or
non-academic philosophy you don't need
to necessarily enroll in college or
university to study philosophy you can
certainly do it on your own and even if
you do you probably will have to study
some of the things you want to study on
your own as well
roughly Bumble says congratulations on
the Milestone my lectures have been a
good way to start your mornings that's
really nice I'm I'm glad to hear that I
think you may have said that before
somewhere else that rings a bell that
you listen to them in the morning maybe
while you're taking a walk or something
is that am I remembering right or not
um
Mark says been reading through Paul's
letters lately reflecting on Galatians
any of these letters that are
significant for you I have mixed
feelings about Paul but I appreciate
some of his views too
um I'm not a huge fan of Paul you know
um I think that and this is going to be
a you know a way out sort of view
that he really
um made a lot of himself as like you
know claiming the the role of apostle
and
um then again you know his letters are
some of the earliest Christian
literature that we have so that's kind
of nice you know kind of cool all right
um
I don't know I'm just I see so many
people using Paul and I think that we
should give more deference to the
gospels
and to the letters by other Apostles
than we should to Paul you know so we
shouldn't be like Lutheran called James
an Epistle of straw James is one of the
you know OG Apostles he's not he's not a
a more recent convert so that's That's
My Views
um sumet says that's really awesome to
hear we're talking about the Indian
civil service exam
I am aware of the exam I'm sure a lot of
aspirants would be learning from your
lectures I'm not an aspirant or academic
student of philosophy but I have a deep
interest to know stuff and loving it
through your lectures oh that's that's
great yeah I don't know how many people
and it's hard where would I get the
statistics for this how many people
actually use my lectures on uh
philosophical topics or thinkers to
prepare for the Indian civil service
exam I I don't know
um I I know that
if I wanted to
make stuff for it I would I would
probably need to label it properly so
that they could find their way to my my
videos
uh Polly mathing says I likewise listen
to them while I watch the sunrise on my
hour-long drive to work yeah okay I've
been there myself I didn't listen to
podcast lectures I I you know this is
back when I was teaching at Indiana
State Prison and I had an hour commute
from
uh Roselawn Indiana up to Michigan City
Indiana and then specifically to the
prison
and I would go to the library
and get CDs and uh copy them and burn
them onto new CDs so I could listen to
stuff so I listened to like for example
the whole Odyssey uh I remember you know
and then I would download things too
from LibriVox
um and you know it's kind of funny
because
there's some philosophical works that I
can listen to while I'm driving and
there's others where I just get
hopelessly lost like I found that I
could listen to Aristotle but Descartes
was I'd start losing the threat of the
argument and then you can't listen to
Hegel while you're driving people who
claim that they're gonna like listen to
the phenomenology on Audible or
something it's hard enough to figure out
what the hell the guy's doing with a
book that you've got in front of your
face I can't see like doing it in a
linear fashion like listening to it
all right roughly Bumble says not me on
the walk while making breakfast
sometimes okay and then any recommended
tricks for using audacity I use it for
LibriVox recordings but I'm very novice
right now
yeah and you know you know who else is
doing that by the way my oldest child
cat
um they're doing LibriVox volunteering
and that's very cool and I I asked uh
cat the other day hey you use an
audacity and they were like yeah and
that that's all I use nowadays so tricks
yeah so you definitely
here's what I'll say because I use it
not just for the podcasts but also like
if I'm recording new stuff you know I've
been experimenting with this Omni course
uploading lectures there and I recorded
lectures for listenable as well
um
you know
leave some gaps because when you look at
the sound file you're going to need
those gaps to do certain things with the
facts so the two effects that I use the
absolute most
basically on every sound file that I'm
working on
one of them is noise reduction and
that's you know there's a two-part
process for that you find like a a place
so like let's say the the air
conditioning is on
um you can't see it but there's like an
air event right above here and so it
could be making a little bit of
background noise right so you use that
little sample where the only thing
that's going on is the background noise
and you sample that and then you do
noise reduction and that gets rid of all
that crap right
um
compressor
I use that pretty much all the time that
kind of evens things out I also will you
know play around with the equalizers
sometimes but that can get a little I
can get a little tricky you know it's
it's uh harder to use effectively but it
can be very helpful like if you've got
too much bass going on or too much too
much high-end travel that can be kind of
nice
um so I you know those are the things
I'm not like a audacity whiz or anything
I don't I don't know how a lot of the
stuff actually works I should probably
do some tutorials so I can up my game so
to speak right but those are the things
that I could say now
all right Mark says do you consider
yourself a pioneer of philosophy on
social media you've developed a
substantial Corpus covering an array of
topics what are some hard lessons from
along the way okay so that's there's a
lot of great stuff there
um am I a pioneer of philosophy on
social media I wouldn't say social media
unless you count YouTube in social media
but I think YouTube is its own kind of
platform
um
I you know there were people doing stuff
before I got on right I started
producing YouTube videos a little over
10 years ago and there were already some
people in the space some of them were
just Kooks you know but some of whom
were were pretty decent
so I'm not a Pioneer but I'm sort of
like the guy who comes after the
pioneers and starts building stuff out
maybe right and
um what are some hard lessons from along
the way
um
planning is important and I have rarely
done much planning I'm usually just sort
of like responding to things and being
like Oh my students need this let me put
some time in and do that it would have
been better for me to do things
better planned out along the way rather
than just flying by the proverbial seat
of my pants but I've been lucky and uh
you know my stuff kind of caught on so
all right NZ
um I listened to simpler works on walks
or while driving like biographies of
Victor Hagel it's still within the
philosophy interest so equally fun for
me but easier to digest yeah yeah
history stuff
biography
um
you know things that are essentially
literary I think those are easier for us
to digest in while we're doing other
things and while we're
listening to them rather than reading
them than straight out philosophy stuff
and part of it is because of the way
philosophy is written you know even
things that have a narrative structure
to them like platonic dialogues they can
be tough to listen to and get enough out
of I would say you know
um Mark says that may help if I start
recording content yeah that's cool Mark
is an educator too uh Mark actually both
Marks here Mark Trumbull and Mark Smith
are both Educators
um so you know
you could make some useful resources I
think for your students
um Paulie mathing I was just going to
ask that exact question advice for
someone starting a new channel oh so
yeah going back to the like uh advice
plan stuff out you know make sure that
if you commit to something you can
actually successfully pull it off so
like you know they say when you like do
a new blog or a new podcast have some
episodes already or some blog posts
already written so that it makes it
easier for you to keep up the um
what do you call it the uh the schedule
right the progression of doing those
sort of things
I I rarely plan and I usually
screw myself over by not planning
adequately but I'm always so busy so it
makes it harder to plan right and I'm
also somebody who has a tendency to
grasp low hanging fruit if I'm you know
I'm like oh there's there's something I
could be doing you know and I go after
the low hanging fruit or as people also
say shiny objects don't get led into
that you know figure out what you want
to do
and then lay out like a schedule for
yourself about what you need to do in
order to make it happen I would say uh
Ben says congratulations Dr Sandler just
got your banjo shirt cheers to five more
years yeah this is the shirt right here
that we're talking about
um I uh I got a free sample from
Teespring because they have this
promotion going on there's actually like
a 25 off coupon code that you can get
um so yeah all right
mbbm is logic essential before venturing
into philosophy will you ever teach
formal logic I have taught formal logic
I just haven't produced videos on it
um
it's been a while since I have taught
formal logic although I am actually
working through with a tutorial student
a logic textbook because she wanted to
do some some logic
um I don't know that I need to produce
content on it because there's already
people out there like Dr logic who
produce great content on it because she
teaches those classes all the time and
you know she's she's uh better at that
sort of thing it's sort of like the you
know why don't I produce videos on
Eastern you know which is not a term I
like to use but that's the term that
everybody uses Chinese philosophy or
Indian philosophy or Islamic philosophy
well because I don't read The Source
languages and there's better people out
there shooting stuff on that why should
I be the one to to produce them
so
um you know I I don't know that I need
to duplicate the work of people that are
already doing a great job
do you need to go into logic before
philosophy you absolutely don't you know
as a matter of fact sometimes with a lot
of philosophy Majors they're the first
logic class sometimes that they get is
in graduate school you know
um if they don't have a logic
requirement as as an undergrad
and you're going to find that formal
logic
despite the hopes and dreams of the
people involved in you know early 20th
century analytic philosophy
you can't do that much with it
unfortunately
it doesn't adequately capture the
structure of much argument you really
need to study rhetoric and study it in a
serious way in order to understand how
argument works well
Polly mathing says thank you thank you
thank you too and thanks to roughly
Bumble for the super I forget what it's
called super something
um all right any other questions
comments people have we got about maybe
another 15 minutes before I got to get
back to uh work for the day before I
have to go to an event tonight where
fortunately I am not speaking my wife is
being honored for having been the
president of the Junior League of
Wisconsin for the Junior League of
Milwaukee for the last two years at the
Women's Club of Wisconsin it's like a
big Gala I got to put on a suit and tie
and head over there and there's the the
band The Five Card studs are playing
which if you know you know if you're
from Milwaukee that's a big deal that
they're playing so there's going to be
dancing and dining and schmoozing and
all that kind of stuff that I gotta
dress up for but any other any other
questions comments uh things people want
me to engage with
oh this is a really interesting question
Reese sparker what are the best miners
to complement a Philosophy degree
I mean that's one of the cool things
about philosophy
is it kind of goes good with everything
it's like tofu you know it it if you're
doing and it is like tofu in this way
right tofu takes on the flavors of what
it's mixed with
so if you're like studying anatomy and
physiology I don't think you can minor
in that but you know you could probably
minor in something connected with that
um
and you you you're a philosophy major
you're going to ask questions about the
human body and how we classify things
that other people studying that won't or
if you're like a theater minor and
you're a philosophy major you're gonna
you're gonna you know start thinking
about things that the others may have an
inkling of but they're not they're not
quite grasping or let's say you're an
accounting Miner although I don't know
if you can mine her in accounting
um usually people I I meet that are
doing accounting are majoring in it
but you could double major right and
you'll start asking all sorts of
interesting questions that they don't
usually want you to ask
right A lot of times people wind up in
philosophy because they pester their
professors with too many foundational
questions and then the professors are
like get the hell out of here go to
philosophy right so you know there
there's all sorts of things I don't
think that there is like one single
set of miners that would be better than
others
um
yeah I think I think philosophy could go
well with just about
just about anything quite frankly and
I'm sometimes surprised
especially at Marquette University when
I asked my students what their majors
are and they're like this thing over
here and philosophy and I'm like wow
that's that's an interesting combination
so all right Chris thanks for all your
effort to bring philosophy to the masses
I've recently been using your series on
Aristotle making my way through the
organ on four weeks and I'm only on in
inter on interpretation but time well
spent I take extensive notes and use
your lectures to add much of them well
that's good yeah I mean I haven't done
on interpretation I haven't done any
videos on it but if I was going to pick
some more of Aristotle's logical Works
to do uh videos on besides the
categories which I have done
on interpretation and on sophistical
refutations would be among them two nice
shorter works and then
um the topics the topics is a massively
undervalued work that's where you see
Aristotle actually saying here's how you
argue for this sort of thing you know
here's the way you look at it you know
particularly the book of the topics
that's on ethical topics which is
getting into the nitty-gritty of like
practical reasoning is just amazing
stuff you know so I hope down the line
to to do some stuff on that I will be
talking about that
this summer actually next month at the
Aristotle and Aristotelian tradition
conference at Marquette University where
I'm I'm going to be doing a paper
on moral values and reasoning in
Aristotle's works and so the topics will
play into that as will the Nick and
McCann ethics and
um the rhetoric and politics and a few
other works as well so yeah
all right we got about 10 minutes left
any other questions comments people
wanna
have me engage with
I have a little bit more of this tasty
beer this groovy mocha Mike Nitro Stone
I don't know if they're still making
this unfortunately
um it's really quite good but I think it
was a a one-off they did
I'll say too I'm looking forward to the
summer I I have two students yet who
have incompletes in my classes
and once I get them resolved and off my
docket I get to do more fun stuff
including I should mention I've got an
Aristotle class starting next week in
the study with Sadler teachable Academy
and we still have spots open for people
who want to study Aristotle on the moral
virtues so Nick and McCain ethics books
two through through six you know
we got a lot of other cool stuff coming
up all right so here we go uh
um polymath and I've been diving into
impedicles this week I don't hear them
talked about much but his ideas seem
very important well you don't hear them
talked about much because we don't
really have full books by empedicles any
more than we do the other pre-socratics
um and you know what we do know is is
largely drawn from other later thinkers
like Aristotle talks about emphatic
leaves quite a lot right
mondavarius what's the best
philosophical sci-fi book wow that
I don't know if there is a best it kind
of depends on what you're looking for
I will say this
um
I mean so there's there's authors that
are like very very explicitly engaged
with philosophy like you know we just
finished up in the worlds of speculative
fiction Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars
Trilogy Where like one of the characters
is actually bringing up gramacion
semantic squares and there's all these
really interesting ethical questions
being formulated and Robinson is super
upfront about what he's doing
um we're doing for this coming month
we're going back to CJ cheras Alliance
Union universe and I've been re-reading
um some of the novels that we're going
to be looking at and holy is she
good
she is probably one of my she's become
one of my favorite authors and you
wouldn't think that the ins and outs of
like running a merchant Starship it you
know the imagination that she has about
that could possibly be interesting but
she makes it interesting and she's so
good at like capturing The Human
Condition now is there like explicit
philosophy in that not not really but
she's really quite good about that
Rhys Parker I'm trying to read the Soma
somate logi I assume for preparation for
second year of undergrad philosophy
specifically my tomistic full year
course it's so hard to read how can I
better understand what's being said well
on that I can actually give you
something
so
um the first thing is to realize that
it's set in a particular format and it's
a dialectical format so Thomas will
begin with a question and then he'll say
here's three arguments it's usually
three arguments against this position
and he's not endorsing any of those
arguments he's just putting them out
there to think about and then they'll be
like
um on the contrary and then they'll be
like usually one argument sometimes two
and there are there are variations there
could be four and two or seven and three
but it's usually like that
and then when you want to see what
Thomas himself thinks
I respond respondio right he he's
telling you what he thinks and then he
explains some things in the the
objections the other thing that I can
say that you can find helpful about
Thomas
he's never discussing a topic fully in
the question or article about that topic
you got to be willing to go around and
see what he says in other places so you
know for example
um
you know he's going to talk about you
know so I've been doing a lot of work on
Thomas and anger and he's got like a
whole question about anger and then all
these articles
but he also talks about it importantly
in other places too or say the Old Law
and the new law in their relation right
there's there's whole sections but then
you got to go to other places and see
what he says so you got to kind of read
around a bit to get Thomas's take on
stuff
uh crucifer maybe is how it's pronounced
uh are you planning to do any videos on
the philosophy of mathematics
you know maybe down the line I'm not
really a specialist in that there might
be some good stuff out there already I'd
have to take a look uh my youngest child
wanted me to do that years ago
um but I don't know if she still wants
me to she's she's already pretty
advanced in mathematics she's up to calc
3. and
doing some other cool stuff
um all right uh
let's see here
uh Ken black well overused term but I
think Aristotle could legitimately be
described as a true genius who is loomed
large over Western thought ever since
you know
we're genius much
but
I mean Plato Aristotle Descartes I think
they could they could be placed in there
um Aristotle was you know I mean he's
wrong about a lot of stuff especially
like when it comes to women you know but
um
he really did have a breadth of thought
didn't he I mean that's quite enviable
and admirable
all right Chris will they be available
for purchase after the fact the
Aristotle class it's available for
purchase right now and I've been
thinking about this
um
so the the Aristotle course that I'm
talking about in the study with Sandler
Academy it meets her 90-minute sessions
eight weeks and uh the settings are
recorded back to them and watch them if
they want to and there's a video about
that in in my Channel right now with
links to going to the course
um and it's for the people who sign up
for the course and there is there is
tuition but it's it's not like break the
bank sort of tuition
um so if you want to do that you
certainly can there's also like a
standalone Aristotle Nick and McCain
ethics course as well but there's also
like tons and tons of free content on
Aristotle in my channel that you can
also watch if you want to you know this
is more like do you want you know
interactive time with the uh person
who's been researching and teaching this
stuff for years and years and years so
that that's the opportunity for that
um
Ben says no question
almost a year into the philosophy Club I
started in my community thanks for the
advice you gave about starting one uh
hopefully others here will find some
people to study with yeah I mean and we
have wonderful opportunities to study
online now there's so many uh forums and
groups and and you know uh different
classes that you can sign up for I mean
think about the fact that we're talking
about a podcast on a YouTube channel
with people all over the world right now
and we're all here in this virtual space
this was not even like on the horizon
When I Was An undergraduate you know now
in grad school we had the internet you
know we were starting to explore it
which was kind of cool
uh Chris says oh okay back to the
Aristotle class I only ask because I
can't make it during the day day job
gets in the way of my reading yeah so so
what I mean some people sign up for the
class and they don't participate in the
sessions but they watch the videos and
then they of the video of the session
and then they participate in the
discussion forums that we have set up
after each of the uh the videos so you
know it's up to you you obviously if you
can't be there for the session it's not
as fun but you can still get a lot out
of it
um
oh Mark says we're talking about no
polymathing linked to the course like I
said it's there's a video on my channel
you got to do a little bit of groundwork
here right I'm I'm doing this I'm not
putting links in places
um just go to the channel and uh where
it says Aristotle eight week class click
on that video click on the link there
Mark says we're talking about Blade
Runner today in a group we used
Aristotle theory of the parts of the
soul to argue oh that's good to argue
whether Androids have souls his thought
was robust if that keeps on giving yeah
that's cool because usually what's the
go-to for Blade Runner the Master Slave
dialectic from Hegel all right it's not
like thinking about whether they have
souls or not
um that's a great question that would be
worth exploring I think
um Abraham says been working through the
Nico McCain ethics udamian ethics Magna
moralia what's your advice on the
udamian ethics uh and Nick McCain ethics
from an order and consent perspective
um I can if I can make time we'll
definitely sign up for Nick of McCain
ethics I don't know what a consent
perspective is but here's here's what I
can tell you most Scholars thank the
Magna moralia is not by Aristotle but
it's Aristotelian right so it's not bad
same thing with virtues and vices
the the consensus among Scholars as far
as like
um ordering is that the the udemian
ethics is earlier and comes from
Aristotle's more influenced by Plato's
phase and the Nico McCain ethics is
later
you know three of the books are the same
in both of them and they're treating a
lot of the same topics in ways that
nicely complement each other
um I don't know I I don't take a stand
on which came first because
[Music]
um
you know
they uh
we don't really know you know and I I
think it's nice to use them both in
conjunction I also think it's fine to
use stuff from the Magna moralia and the
on virtues and vices but we just have to
like say well this isn't Aristotle
himself but this is Aristotelian uh and
I'm I'm cool with that oh Mark posted
the link so uh which is for the whole
teachable Academy
um mondavarius do you have a favorite
platonic dialogue yeah the Symposium
it's it's just the best all right uh
Chris Miles Bernie had explained Plato's
forms in a way I never thought of that
made a lot of sense he says it's not an
otherworldly thing but Plato is talking
universals in particulars and to adhere
to the ideal is to meet a universal
definition of justice yeah I don't buy
that at all I think you know that's
that's clever but it's not platonic you
know there's too much with Plato
actually talking about it being a a
separate thing
uh polymathing posted the link wrote
that message okay good good so we're
we're at the top of the hour I gotta
like I said I gotta get some work done
and then I gotta get ready for this Gala
event here in Milwaukee that I got to go
to but I'm so happy that all of you
could join me for celebrating this uh
this cool Milestone five years into the
Sadler's lectures podcast I'm gonna keep
it up I'll keep doing it and uh you know
I'm gonna keep shooting videos too so
no uh no worries about that I don't know
what YouTube will look like 10 years
from now but hopefully it'll still be
around so yeah I see people signing off
I'll say goodbye and uh thanks for
everybody for uh joining me it's a good
time